so sort of a quest I guess we have a
pirate captain it's called the pirate
captain he's the leader of the crew our
band of misfits they go around pirating
sorry unfortunately captain gets into
his head but this year he's going to win
the part of the Year award so he goes
out and tries to when it is humiliated
embarrassed in front of the rest of the
pirate world feels terrible is going to
give up when he bumps into Charles
Darwin just by a bad life Darwin aim it
and Darwin who is not a very dignified
figure he's very young he's played by
David Tennant who played Doctor Who
Darwin knew as the captain to London
where they meet the real threat in Ruby
which is Queen Victoria yeah poor
defenseless me
makes one really been decision and loses
is cruel and it's the battle to get them
back in it's mostly stops a movie
because that's what we have famous for
doing it in that sense it's very
traditional and I'm doing with them with
a very long established team lots of the
people who work on chicken run lots of
people have worked on the curse of the
where Abbot's and we use like CG
background pirates to flesh out the
crown scenes and because it's a pirate
movie which it is it has a big fat
wonderful pirate ship a lovely lovely
thing it's a sea two ships in England we
say cut and shut it's when you get to
wrecked cars and you sawed in half and
you fit in back together again listen
this is a cut and shut pirate ship and
two two ships badly stuck together and
but it it floats around in the entirely
cgc in the bay convincing way and it
sits on a big a big mechanical rig that
makes it rock and roll and bounce up and
down and then somehow by CG magic they
take that information and put them and
make it sit in the sea I hope it kind of
breaks through onto the screen yeah it's
made by a relatively small team and it's
handmade
you know stop-motion is very hands-on
technology rich literary hands-on yeah
yeah the the animator is an invisible
presence between every frame because we
because they between any two consecutive
moments the amateurs going in for set
and you move the puppets that's the
magic of what we do and so it's a very
funny feeling
you've done captain